figure live bonjour nous sommes en
direct aujourd'hui pour vous faire vivre
la conférence de presse de christophe
galtier le nouvel entraîneur du psg ce
départ zinédine zidane effectivement les
warrants nous avons christophe galtier
aujourd'hui qui est présenté pour en
parler aujourd'hui je suis avec
sébastien ferra bonjour sébastien
comme d'habitude on va essayer de
répondre au mieux à vos questions vous
donc vous n'hésitez pas sur la page
d'accueil du figaro sur notre page
youtube à nous poser vos questions on
essaye d'y répondre au mieux comme
d'habitude
sébastien première question christophe
galtier est ce que c'est un bon choix
pour le psg on va en parler longuement
alors évidemment la question est ce que
c'est le bon choix est ce que ça sera
bien et christophe galtier au psg ça il
ya seulement l'avenir qu'il me dira
maintenant on va essayer de se demander
pourquoi le choix de christophe galtier
qu'est ce qui a poussé le psg dans ce
dans ce choix là s'il y avait d'autres
choix possibles on verra que possible un
pas peut-être pas justement mais en tout
cas il y avait d'autres idées du côté du
psg en tout cas le psg a déjà récupéré
un entraîneur français un des meilleurs
entraîneurs français aujourd'hui sur sur
le marché soirée paisible indie dance et
au travers français un autre trailer
français effectivement en tout cas
c'était la volonté du psg même si la
série qualifie la piaule un petit peu
démenti tout le monde a compris que le
psg voulait zidane ça faisait ça faisait
un moment maintenant si dan a dit non
aujourd'hui on sait qu'on parle beaucoup
plus en équipe de france alors que
l'avenir de didier deschamps est assez
incertain chez chez les bleus zidane a
dit non au psg pour l'instant est ce que
ce n'est que partie remise en tout cas
pour l'instant le psg devra entre
guillemets se contenter de christophe
peut être est ce que on sait s'il y
avait d'autres noms qui circulaient des
grands noms il ya eu d'autres noms n'est
pas forcément justement de grands noms
clairement zidane était vraiment celui
qui est qui sortait du lot à ce niveau
là christophe galtier est finalement
apparu un peu comme un commun comme un
plan b alors bien sûr le psg va pas le
présenter comme ça et essayer de
s'inscrire à un peu dans la durée avec
lui ça peut aussi se défendre par le
fait qu' on parlera notamment de la
direction sportive du psg ça c'est un
gros point de ce nouveau psg en quelque
sorte qui connaît très bien le jeu
comporte exactement le disque en pause
qui a beaucoup travaillé avec avec
galtier habile
donc ça ça tend à penser que galtier
n'est pas jusque là de passage n'arrive
pas par hasard au psg il a clairement
été choisi que il ya une possibilité de
construire un projet assez cohérent une
volonté le temps tout cas de travailler
ensemble ce qui n'a pas toujours été le
cas au psg récemment entre l'entraîneur
et la direction sportive oui
effectivement on va on va en parler je
sais c'est djoko ce qui va et qui nous
rejoint qui me dit galtier va faire le
taf au psg les parisiens peuvent se
réjouir alors c'est vrai toute la
question c'est que galtier c'est un très
bon entraîneur de club on l'a vu avec
saint-etienne on l'a vu avec lille on
regardera un peu sur son parcours un peu
moins avec nice
quand même mais est ce que c est ce que
ça peut marcher d'avec à un vestiaire
collomb c'est assez compliqué quand même
oui la gestion du vestiaire évidemment
elle sera encore encore centrale et
c'est la gestion du vestiaire presque la
gestion de tout le club dans l'ensemble
c'est ce qui a été pointée de manière
générale et les entraîneurs qui ont pu
partir un peu légèrement en conflit avec
le psg ne prêtait pas forcément investir
ingérable ou d où des divas mais il
taclé aussi un petit peu la direction
sportive quelque part est un club qui ne
tournait pas forcément un qui était un
peu un club ou un peu tout le monde fait
ce qu'il veut chacun fait ce qu'il veut
ce qui est important à prendre en compte
je pense encore une fois c'est le
changement la direction sportive le
départ de leonardo l'arrivée de musc en
pause qui a vraiment une réputation
d'une main de fer qui gère bien ses
clubs qui est extrêmement strict très
rigoureux ce qui est aussi un peu le cas
de christophe galtier donc on se dit
qu'à ce niveau là les choses vont être
assez prise au sérieux maintenant
attention j'ai un peu l'impression que
c'est un peu tout le temps le même
discours chaque année avec le psg on a
vu d'ailleurs nsa a qualifié qui a dit
je sais plus quelle formule employée je
crois il a parlé de la fin des
paillettes cette année tous les ans il a
un discours comme ça et il trouve une
autre formule
simple en fait ça me fait un peu penser
au mythe pierre et le loup alors à force
de dire assez la fin des stars c'est la
fin des paillettes on n'a plus très
envie d'y croire mais peut-être qu'un
jour ça sera vraiment le cas on sait
qu'il ya des rumeurs de départ de neymar
ce qui serait retentissant que le tg se
sépare de neymar ça paraît difficile à
faire mais qu'on ait des rumeurs dans ce
sens là on a quand même un peu
l'impression que paix dans votre côté
j'ai en tout cas mais ce qu'il faut mais
les ingrédients pour vraiment changer
allez entre kim et droit jusqu en poste
on le rappelle c'est quand même la
personne qui a réussi à gagner un titre
avec monaco qui a réussi à gagner un
titre avec lille là où il travaille avec
avec christophe gâtés on lisait c'est un
homme de poigne est-ce que lui peut
mettre fin c'est plutôt à galt est de
faire mais lui aussi va mettre un peu le
vestiaire ou pas bien sûr on peut parler
vraiment je pense d'un d'un tandem entre
entre entre cal qui éblouissent campos
et même on en reparlera mais on parle on
parle beaucoup de christophe galtier on
insiste beaucoup sur lui il faudra
parler plus gros plus globalement aussi
du staff de christophe galtier c'est un
point pour le coup je pense qu'on
n'insiste pas assez dessus dans le score
surtout dans les sports collectifs son
rugby basket football où c'est pas un
entraîneur seul aujourd'hui qui dirait
qui dirige une équipe il ya les staffs
très élargie on reviendra sur le fait
que christophe galtier n'a pas toujours
travaillé avec les mêmes adjoint selon
ces clubs c'est peut-être quelque chose
qui a aussi un petit peu fait la
différence à nice où il a lu un passage
n'est pas plus compliqué aujourd'hui il
arrive plus avec une équipe qu'il a
vraiment choisi avec des gens qu'il
connaît
c'est ça qui est très intéressant avec
ce psg c'est que pour une fois on a
l'impression qu'on a vraiment une
direction sportive un entraîneur qui
sont qui sont prêts à aller en tout cas
dans le même sens et qui se connaissent
très bien oui on parle de on parle a
priori de cinq adjoints qui
pourrait venir avec lui on peut revenir
un peu sur ces sur sa carrière déjà ses
c'est à marseille et déjà on peut le
dire oui bon il est né à marseille il a
commencé sa carrière de joueur
professionnel à marseille la pas fine à
marseille mais c'était son dernier club
en france il est revenu il a lancé sa
carrière d'entraîneur adjoint à
marseille aussi il a une grande
affection avec avec le sud avec
marseille avec tout ce coin là et avec
l'om c'est vrai où il a été joueur
entraîneur même s'il était jamais
entraîneur il a jamais été entraîneur
principal de l'om alors je crois qu'il
est entraîneur principal pour un match
mais c'était pour faire
justin terry wey au début des années
2000 maintenant oui gatier il a un lien
fort avec marseille ça peut faire un
petit peu bizarre de voir psg d'un autre
côté on parlait beaucoup de zinédine
zidane aussi une certaine affection que
nous mêmes avec la ville de marseille je
pense pas que ça sera vraiment un sujet
au cours de la saison il y aura des
questions de la presse c'est sûr sur le
sujet cryer apg web c'est évident et
forcément y avoir des artistes un peu là
dessus sur le lien je suis pas sûr que
ce soit vraiment un sujet galtier il a
déjà affronté le web plein de fois dans
sa carrière il a affronté le psg
maintenant il au psg c'est pas c'est pas
vraiment un sujet ça sera plus
anecdotique qu'autre chose et je pense
pas que ça va perturber en tout cas le
club ça va un petit peu agacé les
supporters sur le coup là maintenant ça
les agace un petit peu mais je pense pas
que ça redeviendra du tout un sujet sa
carrière d'entraîneur elle décolle
vraiment à saint-etienne où il affiche
une longe et une longévité assez
incroyable pour pour un coach ouais
c'est la première fois en plus qu'il est
entraîneur principal qu'il est vraiment
de nommé entraîneur principal
effectivement je crois qu'il fait huit
ans à saint-etienne il leur ramène
notamment une coupe de la ligue à une
époque où saint-etienne c'était quand
même difficile il y avait une descente
en ligue 2 une remontée et la russie
vraiment à installer de la continuité
dans ce club va le maintenir plutôt bien
dans le ventre mou voire dans le haut du
tableau
il a même joué la coupe d'europe avec
saint-etienne donc à ce niveau là oui là
il avait réussi d'excellentes choses
maintenant sans manquer de respect bien
sûr à ce qu'il a à faire saint-etienne
qui est énorme je pense que ça ne
servira à rien d'en parler par rapport
au psg parce que déjà ça fait un moment
parce que le foot a beaucoup changé
depuis c'est totalement différent et
aussi parce que ce sont absolument pas
les mêmes clubs les mêmes équipes le
saint-etienne de christophe galtier n'a
rien à voir avec le psg vous face auquel
va se retrouver christophe galtier donc
ça c'est différent je pense qu'on pourra
un peu plus comparé par rapport à ses
expériences à lille et nice oui
effectivement donc ensuite après
indienne il va à lille où il prend la
suite de marcelo bielsa et il remporte
un titre de par exemple et errements
d'un titre de champion de france contre
le psg était super star oui c'est un
titre jaillir incroyable alors le psg
s'était pas la première fois qu'il
équipe et rebelle titre en souviens
qu'on avait aussi
maintenant oui ça a été retentissant
parce que le losc ne s'est absolument
pas partie des favoris pour le titre en
tout cas on se disait pas attention au
losc le losc peut embêter le psg et
pourtant ça a été le cas où galthié a
réussi avec louise campos encore une
fois c'est important d'insister là
dessus il a réussi à appliquer une
méthode qui a eu des résultats alors
avec un jeu pas très chatoyant il a même
vu lui-même reconnu après le titre il a
lady g plus les mots exacts mais du
genre on n'a pas toujours été très beau
mais on a eu du coeur de deux de la
hargne tout çà de là la générosité il
avait dit notamment
donc voilà son losc n'était pas
magnifique mais il est vraiment des
résultats il est aussi la solidité de la
continuité pour ramener un titre de
champion de france bien beaucoup de
clubs qui aimeraient pouvoir en dire
autant lyon marseille monaco plein de
clubs qui ont essayé qui n'ont pas
réussi que là dessus galtier s'est
clairement sa réussite la grande
réussite de sa carrière par contre on
parle de lui comme d'un coach d'accord
comme un grand coach b néanmoins il y a
quand même cette petite ombre au tableau
on peut dire l'an dernier il signe à
nice avec cette étiquette deux
entraîneurs phare il a gagné vient de
gagner un titre et ça se passe pas si
bien que ça non ça se passe pas bien
parce que on a eu des échos récemment
notamment de yoann cardinal anciens de
l'ogcnice qui est toujours très proches
dit assia de certains joueurs et qui a
expliqué que des échos lui qui la lui
c'est que christophe galtier s'était mis
le vestiaire à dos surtout en fait parce
que christophe gatti avait une grande
tension avec sa direction ça c'était
plutôt un secret sur la fin de saison
c'était clair en gagner c'est un petit
peu de minimiser le truc de dire c'est
pas parce qu'une dispute dans un couvent
que tout de suite il ya un divorce on va
en discuter bon finalement il y eut
divorcé un très vite on l'a vu
maintenant
ce sont pas des problèmes à priori qu'on
aura au psg ça serait étonnant que
galtier s'embrouille en tout cas avec
luce campos parce que ils ont voulu se
réunir au psg ils sont très bien connus
la fin a été un petit peu compliqué à
lille où le campo c'était parti galtier
n'est pas trop compris pourquoi il n'est
plus trop de contacts pendant pendant
quelques temps maintenant ils sont
parfaitement réconcilier ils sont ravis
de retravailler ensemble donc a priori
pas ce problème là il y aura peut-être
aux choses à surveiller bien sûr p geste
mais voilà c'est la gestion du vestiaire
des stars
ce qu'on dit à chaque fois que j -pg
chaque année alors on a les premières
images en direct de la conférence de
presse au parc des princes on a
opérationnelle qui me dit j'espère qu'on
gagnera la ligue des champions alors ça
c'est un peu le point noir aussi
christophe gatineau n'a disputé cette
ligue des champions qu'à une reprise
avec lille et on peut pas forcément dire
que ça s'est bien passé non ça s'est
bien passé s'est pas très bien passé
après on attendait pas forcément lille à
ce niveau là on n'attendait pas grand
chose du losc à ce niveau beaucoup là
dessus on ne tiendra pas forcément
rigueur de ses résultats en ligue des
champions et on va pas non plus lui
tenir rigueur de ne pas avoir joué plus
que ça la ligue des champions parce
qu'avec les équipes qu'ils avaient ils
n'avaient pas forcément cette prétention
là il arrive dans une équipe d'un tout
autre niveau de tout ce qu'il a connu
jusqu'à présent maintenant forcément son
expérience ont une expérience en ligue
des champions ben ayed interroge parce
que des entraîneurs qui n'ont aucune
expérience en ligue des champions et qui
arrivent à y performer tout de suite je
sais pas si on a eu beaucoup récemment
en tout cas pas qu'ils ont gagné on dira
de tête zinédine zidane quand même au
real madrid c'est vrai maintenant je
pense que c'est un contexte totalement
différent l'entraîneur qui veulent
qu'ils étaient déjà au club depuis des
années car était exempt de chez naughty
qui connaissait le vestiaire qui avait
une équipe qui avait un certain héritage
tactique technique tout ce qu'on veut se
connaît a aujourd'hui le psg qui à lui
des fins très très compliqué avec avec
punch et hino donc oui on a une
expérience de gatti à ce niveau là
forcément elle interroge
il va falloir qu'ils trouvent des
réponses très vite forcément mais ce qui
est rassurant c'est qu'il connaît très
bien la ligue 1 et qui va peut-être
pouvoir apporter cette continuité en
ligue 1 c'est ce qui a manqué au psg là
la saison dernière c'est ce qui leur a
coûté aussi en ligue des champions on
n'a pas senti une équipe unie on l'a pas
senti un groupe qui savaient répondre à
différentes problématiques c'est ce
qu'il aura pas mal coûté face au real
madrid et là-dessus christophe galtier
pourra peut-être pour tout cas apporté
les réponses et on a eu avec lui je suis
sûr que galtier valve à le faire un bon
travail paris a même map et messi neymar
il peut faire quelque chose alors oui
ils peuvent faire quelque chose là toute
la question c'est de voir comment un
parent est inexpérimenté mais un
entraîneur qui n'a pas l'habitude de
gérer ses stars va réussir à gérer cette
fois ci et les mettre au pas c'est ça
alors moi j'ai tendance à penser qu'en
dans l'absolu dans la gestion des stages
spectacles de cirque a explosé on en
n'est absolument pas là surtout parce
que encore une fois christophe galtier
parfaitement soutenu par l'usc en pause
puis se compose et soutenu par quartier
travailler ensemble nasser al-khelaifi a
l'air de vraiment faire confiance à
brice campos en tout cas lui donner
beaucoup de pouvoir donc à ce niveau là
les joueurs n'auront pas grand chose à
dire il ne rompt pas un patron vraiment
ou alors prêtre qui pourront se plaindre
elle ira ça ça va pas moi je suis pas
content ça sera plus difficile pour les
joueurs donc je pense que ça va aller à
ce niveau là
maintenant c'est surtout qu'il faudra à
leur apporter les choses leur apporter
des réponses techniques et tactiques
pour les mettre dans les meilleures
conditions
trouver la bonne formule notamment
qualifié on sait que certains grands
grand fan du 4 4 2 assez classique avec
un bloc mais bon le truc assez assez
classique il a qui lui a permis d'être
champion de france avec lille qui va
bien qu'il a mis en place à nice aussi
par la suite exactement on a du mal à
voir comment le psg pourrait jouer comme
ça et il s'était beaucoup une question
avec paul chez tino de comment jouer
avec les trois stars messi neymar me
taper là dessus forcément il y aura des
questions sur un 4-4-2 sa demande a
aussi beaucoup de travail défensif de la
part des fans de stars alors qu'on a
beaucoup parlé à saison dernière du
fameux 7 + 3 17 joueurs qui défend et
les trois de devant qui sont tous seuls
isolés du coup une équipe en fait qui
n'en est pas une elle m'a peiné mais si
neymar effectivement offert jouer à
cette affaire je vais trois jours pareil
ça force à faire des compromis de
l'autre clinton c'est ça donc c'est
aussi là dessus qu'il faudra peut-être
les convaincre ont trouvé en tout cas la
bonne formule qui permettra vraiment otg
de jouer en équipe je pense que
christophe cas qui a quand même été
choisi là dessus en tout cas je pense
que c'était vraiment d'une des
réflexions du psg de se dire christophe
galtier est l'homme qui peut permettre
d'apporter de la cohésion et de la
solidité à ce niveau là alors on à
sofiane du lycée quand que galtier entre
alors la conférence de presse est prévue
pour 14h mais avec ce genre d'événement
ça peut démarrer toujours un peu plus
tard on se rappelle m ap mais si ils ont
tendance à arriver sainte 10000 plus
tard parfois 20 mai ont demandé ensemble
n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions
boubacar kébé galtier n'est pas l'homme
de la situation alors ça c'est
intéressant n'est pas l'homme de la
situation est ce qu'il y avait vraiment
d'autre choix à part zidane dont on a
parlé est ce qu'il y avait d'autres
choix d'autres entraîneurs à prendre sur
le marché actuellement déjà ce qui
paraissait clair c'est flopée je ne
pouvais pas continuer avec poggetti dans
ça c'était inenvisageable et les
dernières semaines ont été on frôlait
avec le ridicule les déclarations
tout et son contraire a été dit par paul
chez tino par la direction sportive donc
c'était obligatoire de vraiment changer
les choses maintenant un autre
entraîneur à par zinedine zidane
christophe galtier il ya quelques noms
qui ont fuité passe par ci par là mais
il n'y a pas forcément d'entraîneur je
sois notamment de ruben amorim par
exemple de l'entraîneur du sporting
portugal dont on a parlé pareil aucune
expérience en ligue des champions et
aucun entraîneur qui vraiment s'imposer
qui semblait en tout cas naturel pour le
pga par galtier ou zidane on à oscar
maurice avant que galles qui arrive il
est il est sur le chemin du midi est ce
que l'on pense qu'il va faire une
annonce surprise du mercato ton pas en
conférence de presse non c'est pas du
tout dans les tuyaux a priori non alors
on va vous laisser suivre cette
conférence de presse et on revient après
pour tous débriefer bien évidemment on
voulait s'assurer saad fuite
bonjour à tout bon jour à tous bienvenue
au parc des princes le paris saint
germain est très heureux de vous
accueillir aujourd'hui pour la
conférence de presse de présentation du
nouvel entraîneur du paris saint germain
monsieur christophe galtier d'ici
quelques secondes vous pourrez poser vos
questions nous vous demanderons juste
d'attendre que le micro vous parviennent
de donner le nom du média que vous
représentez votre nom mais avant ça je
laisse la parole aux présidents du paris
saint-germain monsieur nasser
al-khelaifi
pour deux jours à tous
j'espère vous passez vos vacances si
vous avez commencé la vacance de choses
bienvenus
parce qu'en france on n'en sait notre
nouveau très la
coach fausses peuvent gagner je suis
très heureux d'être là au côté lui
on a aussi avant ça je vous remercie
pour cetin aux autres ceci entraînant
contre le travail l'a fait avec sa star
les coaches tant que coach je fais
beaucoup de choses avec nous je souhaite
le meilleur pour lui aujourd'hui
notre entraîneur qui sait on à nouveau
ra pour commencer aussi nouveau en
concurrence au nouveau un patient aussi
la motivation diact être
vraiment je suis président pierre aussi
christophe je pense vous connais bien
coach là on a
vraiment la regarder le coach à voir
qu'on est et saint-etienne après lille
nice on est
content
fier des français aussi on va commencer
des choses niveau aussi de leur projet
merci défaut s'il veut dire des choses
après votre caution peut-être n'a su
préserver
vous dire que je suis ému
oui vous dire que je suis fier oui je
suis arrivé il ya peu près 45 minutes
ici au parc et parc des princes symbole
du football français il ya une phrase
ici qui s'appelle ici c'est paris
quand vous êtes face à cette phrase là
vous sentez de suite les attentes qu'il
peut y avoir
de la part
de vous les spécialistes si la part des
supporters
et à part pas voir ses attentes là
évidemment qu'il va falloir tous
ensemble travailler dans le bon sens
pour rendre les gens heureux
je mesure je mesure mais de manière très
précise
la responsabilité qui m'est donnée de
faire en sorte que le passage à même
vivent une grande saison
avec de grands matches avec désespoir
je me suis préparé
si j'ai accepté ce poste
si j'ai accepté de prendre ses
responsabilités la sais que j'en suis
capable
mais
seul
c'est très difficile ensemble on est
beaucoup plus fort et c'est aussi
lorsque j'ai eu mes premières
discussions avec louise campos
qui m'a parlé de ce projet là
je ne mettrai pas à prendre ma décision
même si je savais je mesurais tout
tout ce qui pouvait se passer dans une
vie d'entraîneur comme son entraîneur du
paris-sg jamais évidemment que la
présence de louise campos opg a été un
élément déterminant et ensuite
évidemment que les mots les échanges que
j'ai pu avoir avec
mon président on fait que j'ai accepté
avec beaucoup d'humilité mais avec une
grande détermination
le poste d'entrée par l'entraîneur du
paris saint germain
il ya beaucoup d'attentes
c'est normal il ya des gens sceptiques
je veux comprendre
je suis prêt donc à répondre à toutes
vos questions
olivier tallaron canal+ la question qui
revient le plus souvent chez les
supporters c'est ce que christophe
quelques mètres capable de gérer un tel
vestiaires avec de telles stars on peut
citer bape et démarre messi est ce qu'il
ya un secret pour gérer un tel
vestiaires et quelle est votre méthode
pour gérer de telles égaux
évidemment que cette question elle se
pose
mais avant de parler de ça ce sont avant
tout des joueurs des joueurs qui veulent
gagner
qui veulent jouer qui vont le prendre du
plaisir
évidemment que je vais beaucoup échangé
avec
l'ensemble des joueurs j'ai rencontré
des vestiaires où il y avait beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'ego aussi possible
et je pense que la gestion d'un groupe
et c'est un privilège d'avoir un
effectif de ce niveau là avec des
joueurs de classe mondiale
c'est un privilège pour un entraîneur je
pense que la première des choses c'est
d'échanger partager avec eux mais aussi
d'imposer
d'imposer il n'y aura pas de compromis
dans ce que doit être
la force du groupe ce que par rapport
aux objectifs qui sont définies on doit
avoir un projet commun sans aucun
compromis
je ne vais pas
révolutionner le vestiaire je vais
observer écouter et je sais que j'aurai
l'appui de tout le monde de la direction
pour prendre des décisions que je
voudrais prendre à partir de beaucoup un
bon joueur et quel que soit le joueur ne
se pliera pas à ce qui est le projet et
je le vois il n'y aura aucun compromis
là dedans
bonjour que c'est un fin 2005 le
parisien bonjour au psg il faut gagner
mais il faut aussi séduire ça sera quoi
où ce serait quoi le style christophe
galtier
oui il faut avant tout gagner
mais bien évidemment quand vous avez un
tel effectif et que vous êtes deuxième
club avec cette grande réputation sur la
place internationale vous devez bien
joué généralement vous gagnez plus
souvent quand vous jouez bien
par rapport à ce que j'ai pu faire
dans les clubs les clubs dans lesquels
j'ai travaillé évidemment qu'il y a y
aura une approche différente sur le jeu
je vais avoir ma disposition des joueurs
de très haut niveau
paris a très souvent la possession de
balle paris a très souvent en face des
équipes tableau avec des blocs bas il
faudra qu'on arrive à pouvoir à la fois
bien attaquer met une grosse pression
sur sur les adversaires gardez un juste
équilibre c'était c'était qui livre là
est très très important mais bien
évidemment que ça ressemblera pas du
tout à ce que j'ai pu faire auparavant
dans les autres clubs parce que j'ai à
ma disposition des joueurs de niveau
incroyable
le rectorat un petit sport je prends de
la question de dominique est-ce que vous
pouvez nous parler un peu du système
justement est ce que vous avez dit vous
n'avez pas continuer ce que vous avez
fait auparavant le 4 4 2 est ce que vous
allez passer une défense à trois et vous
savez déjà est-ce que vous avez déjà
parlé de ça avec les joueurs donc je
n'ai pas encore rencontré les joueurs
évidemment que j'en ai parlé avec la
direction sportive
tout d'abord je m'adapterai à l'effectif
qui sera à ma disposition puisque les
ans dans une période où il va y avoir
beaucoup de rumeurs beaucoup aussi
beaucoup de mouvements mais oui j'ai une
idée assez précise de ce que je veux
voir de l'équipe avant de parler de
système je veux voir du rythme de
l'intensité de la grande détermination
de capacité à récupérer le ballon très
haut très haut pour pouvoir mettre sous
pression l'adversaire
à partir du moment où je suis rentré
donc
en discussion sur le projet sportif avec
luis mais aussi avec le président
jour là ce qui se passe sur les équipes
de champion's league des équipes de très
haut niveau et je m'aperçois qu'il faut
avoir un modèle de jeu très précis avec
une organisation très précises rarement
le changer et à l'heure où on se parle
en fonction de l'effectif que j'aurai ma
disposition il faudra que je mette sur
tous les joueurs dans leurs meilleures
conditions et sur leur point fort donc
vous dire évidemment que j'ai pu lire
je vous ai lu je vous ai écoutés faisait
pas vous regarder
on parle beaucoup d'une défense à trois
avec une grande participation de nos
pistes au
j'ai la chance d'avoir de cette
équipe-là des couloirs incroyable mais
c'est aussi à l'intérieur du jeu de
savoir qui fera partie de l'effectif
pour savoir quelles animations on aura
aussi à l'intérieur du jeu mais il ya
une grande orientation sur une défense à
trois
si damien degorre l'équipe tu parlais de
la présence de louise campos qui a été
déterminante dans ton dans sa décision
est ce que tu peux nous dire comment tu
travailles comment tu as travaillé avec
louise par exemple à lille au quotidien
comment vous gérez comment vous discutez
de quoi vous discuté ce que je luis
participe à la gestion de l'effectif
t'aide à gérer l'effectif au quotidien
est ce que toi tu as ton mot à dire sur
le recrutement est sûre selon les
besoins et les joueurs où tu ne veux
plus
avec qui nous avons travaillé plus de
trois ans l'ensemble ce sont des
échanges permanents
qu'ils soient sur place ou en
déplacement pour préparer toujours
l'avenir du club suisse anticipe
beaucoup les choses dont la relation
permanente sur la construction de
l'équipe c'est ce que j'attends de mon
équipe ce que je veux voir de mon équipe
évidemment que avant de partir sur le
recrutement nous avons beaucoup échangé
je répète encore une fois luis mais
aussi le président sur le système et en
fonction du système luis a cette
capacité à découvrir à convaincre des
joueurs de venir nous rejoindre
est-ce que lui ce fait un recrutement
oui mais
depuis trois ans nous avons travaillé
nous avons fait beaucoup de mercato
ensemble n'est jamais un joueur n'est
venu sans mon accord c'est très clair
mais il a j'ai une totale confiance sur
cette capacité à trouver les joueurs qui
vont faire que peu faut faire que tout
va bien fonctionner
c'est un bon jour marque le chinois
goal.com je vais prolonger la question
d'un confrère est ce que votre relation
de travail avec lui ce campus dépasse le
cadre du mercato et en quoi est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer en quoi ça
dépasse sa vie en relation avec
l'organisation tronic à partir de luis
est en charge d'un responsable de du
recrutement et la relation directe au
départ des rencontres avec avec le
joueur et son environnement
s'il ya bien quelqu'un qui connaît au
mieux les joueurs c'est lui puisqu'il
les rencontres très souvent ils
échangent très souvent avec eux avec
leur environnement aussi il y à aussi
dans la gestion du quotidien il à ce que
moi j'attends de voir
de l'avis du groupe de l'investissement
des joueurs et quand il ya des choses
qui ne me plaisent pas il ya évidemment
mon intervention mais à mon intervention
il ya aussi toujours des échanges avec
luis pour mesurer
et évaluer les décisions que nous allons
prendre et certainement
jamais je ne prends une décision sans
avoir le point de vue et le partage avec
luis
moi je christophe julien hababou de m6
christophe galtier c'est un marseillais
qui débarque à paris c'est une réflexion
qu'on a pas mal entendu ces derniers
jours ces dernières semaines parce que
ça dure le feuilleton comment vous
positionner par rapport à cela je suis
l'entraîneur du paris saint germain je
suis né à marseille c'est un fait
donc savez on fait un métier de passion
et qu'elle vous avez une telle passion
qui
on veut gagner on cherche le maire loi
pour pouvoir gagner on doit le connais
les meilleurs joueurs on veut gagner le
furent les plus gros trophée et il n'y a
pas le meilleur pas meilleur endroit
autre que le paris saint-germain quand
il ya eu les premiers contacts établis
j'ai mis de côté ce côté mes origines
mes origines marseillaises et croyez moi
que depuis
depuis pas mal de semaines mes jours et
mes nuits sont consacrés au passé jamais
mais ces bonnes choses c'est vrai pour
quelqu un très bon coach de marseille
c'est bon vent pareil c'est pas mon nom
présente question pour vous aussi loïc
terme ces sports de nouveau il est pas
mal de rumeurs ces dernières semaines
sur une arrivée possible de zidane au
psg est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer quand est-ce que vous avez les
premiers contacts avec christophe
galtier et nous confirmer que c'était
bien votre premier choix je serais
content parce que mon corps est coaché
les lacs au témoin me demandait de
ciseaux
comme j'ai dit la dernière invasion
jamais on a parlé avec zidane
g j'adore mes joueurs ils adorent le
coach aussi toi le respecte pour lui
mais j'ai mis la barre des fruits
coach christophe galtier d'interruption
une loi pour nous toujours depuis le
premier jour on a pensé doit de vendre
et là elle est là très fier très content
j'espère c'est la der en fait si on veut
des sceaux faisait merci
giovanni castaldi la chaîne équipe
bonjour christophe une petite question
sur les mares vous avez parlé de votre
effectif est ce que vous projetez avec
neymar est ce que vous voulez le retenir
à tout prix et si oui comment vous
comptez l'utiliser
neymar est un joueur de classe mondiale
il fait partie des meilleurs joueurs au
monde quel entraîneur ne souhaiterait
pas à voir neymar dans son effectif
c'est tout
ensuite évidemment il y a je parlais
tout à l'heure
de toujours à trouver un équilibre
dans une équipe quelle que soit nouveau
quelle joueuse avait besoin d' équilibre
mais j'ai une idée bien précise de ce à
une idée très précise de sur ce que
j'attendrais de neymar je vais le
rencontrer je n'ai pas encore rencontré
je vais aussi être à l'écouté de ce
qu'il va dire et de ses attentes
mais bien évidemment que je souhaite que
de neymar reste chez nous parce que
comme vous êtes des joueurs de classe
mondiale c'est toujours mieux d abord
avec le contre
bonjour christophe sirugue de la
morinerie du service des sports d'europe
avec jacques mandrou ici présent
question pour continuer sur l'effectif
c'était le grand feuilleton et la grande
joie ici à paris c'est la prolongation
qui viennent bape et vous aller
entraîner
kilian bape et ce n'est pas rien comment
vous voyez comment vous allez faire en
sorte pour vous appuyer pour puisqu'il a
un rôle très important aujourd'hui au
psg comment vous allez le manager qu'est
ce que vous attendez de lui oui il ya
killian mais il ya aussi tous et par
tous ses partenaires qui se répètent à
haute-voix des joueurs de classe
internationale
tout d'abord en tant qu'entraîneur
français j'étais très heureux que kilian
prennent la décision de rester au paris
saint germain
c'est bien pour notre football c'est
bien pour notre championnat évidemment
mais c'est aussi bien pour le paris
saint germain qui en fait partie des
meilleurs joueurs au monde
je ne je n'ai pas échangé avec lui j'ai
pu lire quelques fois que j'avais eu des
échanges avec ilan j'ai eu aucun échange
avec aucun des joueurs
de l'équipe mais je sais ce que ce qui n
attendent de l'équipe
on sait ce qu'il apporte à l'équipe on
connaît ses points forts il va falloir
aussi non pas lui donner toute la
responsabilité de et le poids du
résultat
qu'il y ait un joueur
sûrement un des meilleurs joueurs au
monde actuellement
notamment tout si un joueur du paris
saint germain et je pense que
toutes ces grandes individualités qui
qui seront avec qui je vais être tout à
l'heure
si
ces grandes divinités sont au service du
collectif
le psg fera une grande saison 1 pg sera
une grande équipe pour reprendre plus
précisément soit sur killian kiely en
est un joueur talentueux jeune joueur
sur lequel il ne faut pas rajouter de la
pression il devra s'exprimer que le
joueur de l'équipe en étant je l'espère
aux comptes fois autant décisif qu'il a
pu l'être lors de la dernière saison
mais ça nous reste un joueur d'un
collectif qui doit être très fort
bonjour arthur pérou rmc sport une
question pour le président maintenant
que le nouveau coach est aussi le
nouveau staff sont en place quels
objectifs vous fixez pour cette nouvelle
saison notamment en ligue des champions
après la dernière campagne compliquée
merci beaucoup
notre objectif on joue mieux on ne
travaille plus on est collector sur le
terrain extérieur
une était
même aussi sur le terrain extérieur même
dans le management de les spots de
permettre aussi de la manne du monde
avec l'ap tout le monde veut cela
joe mieux
comment on regarde notre équipe quand on
joue avec plaisir un jour bon football
pour une faute je pensais d'un plus
important après les résultats bien sûr
il faut pas parler de la libye
aujourd'hui on n'a pas commencé à
l'appeler mentalement
je pense
la vie active c'est travaille chaque
jour quand on a grande finale tous les
jours c'est là où je vais travailler
travailler travailler pour le faire le
mieux progressé bonjour tout le monde
ensemble collector une équipe qu'est ce
que j'adore chez le coach christophe et
les deux c'est comment vous faire ça on
est vraiment très motivé pour regarder
notre équipe de la premier match mais je
pense qu'après le match commence
aujourd'hui le premier entraînement
c'est le premier match pour nous et on
travaille
tout le monde motiver tout le monde lui
donne tout 100% sur entraînement après
on veut voir les états mais vraiment
notre résultat aussi bien sûr gagner
mais avec
la fin de ce fait le style de jouer
aussi c'est très important on a comme il
faut cela dit on a un grand joueur
mondial avec classe mondiale mais aussi
les jeunes talents c'est très important
avec le nouveau centre d'entraînement
pour nous aussi pour les flammes je
pense tout ça si on semble vraiment vous
concentrer pour la sortie aussi de
nouveaux clients et bien d'autres c'est
toujours l'équipe 1 l'année dernière il
ya eu un autre feuilleton il ya peu que
le feuilleton qui aiment à payer celui
des gardiens est ce que tu vois cette
saison tu va choisir un numéro un et
civil lequel je vais rencontrer très
rapidement les gardiennes
j'ai vu la gestion qu'il ya eu sur sol
et de vos des gardiens mais je n'ai pas
à la commenter
je ne peux pas vous dire encore je dois
rencontrer mais mes gardiens mais j'ai
par principe de toujours nous met un
numéro un et numéro 2 mais ce numéro 2
peut passer numéro vert en fonction des
performances des uns et des autres mais
je fonctionne
toujours comme ça rires je trouve qu'il
est me concernant plus simple en terme
de gestion est aussi plus simple pour
eux
de savoir de savoir quelle est leur
position au sein de l'effectif
bonjour un chaînage pour bfm une
question pour le président
qu'est ce que vous pensez que christophe
galtier va pouvoir apporter de plus que
pochettino a porté pendant un an et demi
et est ce que les retours anticipés des
cadres de l'effectif aujourd'hui sont
déjà le premier effet de le sucre estat
gatier
de moi j'aime pas comparer entraîneur à
vélo son entraîneur parce que j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour tout le monde
on a aujourd'hui coach corse le gâter
notre entraîneur hongrois de lui
vraiment on a comme j'ai dit on après
quand on est avec nous aujourd'hui
l'entraîneur du paris saint-germain
tiers
parce que je sais je suis sûr confiance
de vos portes et beaucoup de choses pour
l'équipe collector le style de jeu le
système comme on le veut utiliser sur
les joueurs sur le nabucco joueurs aussi
con de crise et sur le terrain
collector
l'équipe de spirit de l'équipe aussi
c'est très important dans le goal mans
là
pour nous aujourd'hui c'est très
important tout le monde je respecte
d'arguments avec sur luis cambos vous m
déjà là être l'argument de l'équipe de
foot qu'il vous jouez avec par
l'enseignement le maillot d'un maillot
de pression doit être fier jouer est
très fier elle est la firme retravailler
avec notre coach avec louise pour paris
saint germain le club le plus grand de
tout le monde perd 5 millions de la
clape
si tout le monde vous le respectez nos
moi je suis le premier verset je veux
défendre les joueurs s'ils respectent
dans le monde la clape mais si quelqu'un
ne vont pas respecter et n'a pas plaçant
le club l'équipe
bonjour christophe antoine magnan pour
l' agence france-presse vous disiez tout
à l'heure que vous ne feriez pas de
compromis avec les joueurs une fois vous
aurez parler avec eux qu'est ce que ça
veut dire concrètement est-ce que vous
êtes prêts à écarter les joueurs qui
seraient pas dans le projet même s'il y
en a plusieurs à ne pas les faire jouer
les mettre sur le côté de l'entraînement
complètement merci
le président vient de répondre à cette
question est évidemment qu'il est
toujours important d'abord le soutien et
l'appui de son président par rapport à
cela
en face la manière de travailler avec
luis et qu'il n'y a aucun compromis
l'exigence le travail de respect et
l'équipe avant toute chose
il y aura une amende comme dans tout
groupe
quelquefois
quelquefois quelques manquements ça peut
arriver mais on va faire en sorte qu
année le moins possible les décisions
seront prises il n'y aura aucun joueur
au dessus de l'équipe mon objectif
évidemment c'est pas de leur apprendre à
jouer frapper du pied gauche frappé du
pied droit ou être bon de la tête c'est
de faire en sorte que cette somme de
talents
cette somme de talents deviennent nos
grandes équipes avec une grande force je
suis
convaincu depuis des semaines
je suis déterminé à faire en sorte que
cette équipe
soit très soudée
exigeante déterminé
pour faire la plus grande saison
possible si il y a malheureusement des
joueurs qui sortent de ce cadre là
mais à partir de là où ils sortiront de
ce cadre là ils seront écartés de quelle
manière ça ça restera évidemment
toujours un interne mais je pourrais
répondre très précisément à un joueur
sera au dessus de
ce que doit être le groupe est la
position du groupe
on va prendre deux dernières questions
s'il vous plaît
christophe est à l'avant canal+ juste
pour prolonger ce que disait mon
confrère tout à l'heure des joueurs sont
revenus plus tôt visiblement peut-être
nous le confirme il devait revenir je
pense lundi prochain notamment messi
neymar qui a zappé ce un peu plus
habituel est ce que vous y voyez un
signe justement que les joueurs ont
compris le message qu'il y aura plus de
passe-droit plus de un peu plus de
discipline un peu plus de motivation à
montrer sous là vous voyez un signe
c'est la rentrée d'être là faisait quand
on était petit à la rentrée des classes
on avait le beau cartable trousse de
toilette les cahiers bien rangé le
premier jour tout est nickel
mais n'est pas parce qu étant beaucoup
plus sérieux sur cela
les derniers joueurs rentreront le 11
il y avait d une date définie on l'a
fait en sorte de raccourcir les délais
de vacances pour que tout le monde
rentre le plus rapidement possible
évidemment c'est très agréable que tout
le monde soit l'heure les joueurs qui
sont arrivés ce matin au passé leurs
examens médicaux commencé aussi à
travailler chevalet rencontré pour la
première fois dans l'aube en quelques
minutes mais
était prévu que les marais et les eaux
entre aujourd'hui
bonjour christophe benjamin corrèze du
parisien le président a fait savoir dans
nos colonnes que le ping ping était
terminée au psg est ce que vous vous
considérez comme un coach anti bling
bling
je vais vous dire souvent quand on
prépare des conférences de presse
c'est d'anticiper évidemment des
questions dieu sait qui allait en avoir
c'est la
bling bling non je suis un entraîneur
très exigeant qui aiment voir son équipe
travaillent et qui aiment boire les
joueurs travaillent et qui aiment voir
aussi les joueurs heureux
il n'y a pas de performance et de
grandes performances sans des joueurs
heureux je vais faire en sorte à travers
le travail à travers notre relation je
vais faire en sorte que les joueurs se
sentent heureux à la fois dans le
vestiaire et sur le terrain pour qu'il
soit heureux puisque je vais développer
plus je pense que l'effectif doit être
réduit
je pense que l'effectif de réduit on en
a beaucoup parlé aussi avec la direction
on ne peut pas avoir dans le vestiaire
pendant toute une saison des joueurs qui
ne joue pratiquement pas les joueurs qui
ne jouent pas sont malheureux la
première des choses c'est qu'ils sont
malheureux et puis il ya déjà malheureux
moins vous avez de performance on va
faire en sorte de réduire et trouver le
bon effectif et la bonne taille de
l'effectif pour faire en sorte que tout
le monde puisse participer à cette
saison
merci beaucoup à tous on va faire la
dernière photo et ce sera la fin de
cette conférence de presse
c'est beaucoup
et voilà vous venez de suivre la
conférence de presse de christophe
galtier qui pose en ce moment avec le
maillot du psg fargnoli première très
bonne impression on verra pour la suite
christophe galtier qui s'est dit fier et
ému ensemble on est plus fort avec le
collectif il a mis en avant beaucoup la
valeur travail sébastien pendant cette
conférence de presse quand même oui
beaucoup dans cette idée que il va il
veut vraiment avoir un vestiaire qui qui
va aller dans le même sens qui va tirer
dans le même sens en temps une fois ça
rejoint un petit peu ce qu'on avait dit
avant la conférence de presse de ce psg
la saison dernière qui n'allait pas
toujours dans le même sens avec ce
fameux 7 + 3 convoyés sur le terrain
avec les trois messi mbappé neymar qui
avait l'impression d'être un peu isolé
d'être ne pas avoir vraiment eu une
équipe et christophe galtier insiste
beaucoup là dessus a beaucoup insisté là
dessus aujourd'hui d'une équipe qui va
dans le même sens qui tire dans le même
sens d'un vrai groupe en tout cas unis
et d'une même direction en nette hausse
au sein du club alors on va vous mettre
les images en différé delà de la
conférence de presse vous avez tout
entendu de ce qu'il a dit mais juste
pour que vous ayez un peu de d'habillage
on va disent on va dire il ya pas mal de
sujets qui ont été qui ont été apportées
vous n'hésitez pas à vous à nous dire un
peu dans les commentaires ce que vous
avez pensé de cette prestation de
christophe galtier en conférence de
presse si selon vous c'est le bol
entraîneur ce que vous en avez pensé
voilà oscars - si vous faisiez enfin un
homme de poigne et directif et lui il a
dit je veux voir du rythme de
l'intensité
ouais alors sur le sur l'idée homme de
poigne directif je sais pas si le tg a
attendu christophe galtier pour pouvoir
voir ça je pense que d'autres
entraîneurs au psg avait quand même
c'est maîtrise de l'effectif on a parlé
tout à l'heure pendant la conférence de
presse de gagner moi je pensais à thomas
stovell par exemple qu'ils maîtrisaient
parfaitement son groupe au psg ça irait
jamais eu de souci avec les joueurs du
tlm s'est appréciée de certains joueurs
donc il aime bat et là dessus il n'y a
pas eu de problème je pense pas que
poggetti noël non plus manqué de
maîtrise avec les joueurs je pense pas
qu'il se soit fait entre guillemets
piétiné par les joueurs est là dessus il
n'y a pas forcément de problème et je ne
pense pas que ça sera long plus le cas
de christophe galtier par contre pour
les anciens pour les ancien entraîneur
du psg le problème se trouvait plutôt
avec la direction sportive et ça
déteigne est parfois un petit peu sur
sur le vestiaire c'est d'ailleurs c'est
exactement ce qui est arrivé à
christophe galtier a nice c'est yann
cardinal anciens de l'ogcnice qu'est les
échos du vestiaire qui a dit que de ce
qu'il a entendu effectivement il y avait
des problèmes que galtier me cachais pas
avec la direction et que ça finit par
déteindre sur le vestiaire qui a fini
par toucher certains joueurs et que ça
un petit peu touchés l'ambiance du
vestiaire donc là dessus sur le rapport
entraîneur joueur je pense qu'il aura
pas de problème la question c'est plus
par rapport à la direction et encore une
fois je pense que le psg vraiment
rassuré là dessus parce qu'on a un
conseiller sportif plus ou moins
directeur sportif avec miss campos qui a
choisi christophe galtier qui a passé
des années à travailler avec les habiles
qui a très bien réussi ils sont ravis se
retrouver vont dans le même sens et le
discours de christophe galtier en
conférence de presse marchais dans cette
même direction dont on travaille
ensemble on sait où on va donc là dessus
on est assez rassuré je pense pas que y
ait tant de problème normalement en tout
cas pour l'instant il n'y a pas de quoi
s'inquiéter sur la maîtrise du vestiaire
alors on à aboubakar qui me dit merci de
nous avoir fait suivre
ce direct merci à vous en tout cas
d'avoir été présent tout au long on va
continuer à en parler un peu julien qui
me dit prestation bidon il joue les gros
bras mais quand le prince lui dira ce
qu'il doit faire il déchantera comme
tous les autres est ce que peut-être le
problème du psg ne se trouve pas au
niveau des colts directeur sportif mais
au niveau du propriétaire peut être ce
qui est intéressant c'est que des
derniers échos convaincu c'est que non
leonardo a été débarqué de son poste de
directeur sportif qu'aux novices campos
est arrivé pour prendre un petit peu les
mêmes fonctions et tout ce qui ressort
c'est que miss campos a énormément de
pouvoir au sein du paris saint germain
qui l'a vraiment là quasiment la
mainmise sur l'effectif sur les choses à
appliquer et lui même a voulu christophe
galtier donc à partir de là on a
l'impression que les choses sont bien
déléguer et qui a bien ce côté
entraîneurs qui entraîne directeur qui
dit qui dirige les présidents qui
préside donc à pas a priori le pg va
plutôt dans le bon sens dans cette
démarche en tout cas j'ai pas le
souvenir ces dernières années qu'on ait
vu autant de signaux positifs
parfois on a eu des beaux discours et là
on en a encore c'est pas là dessus qu'on
va vraiment s'attarder parce que parfois
c'est un petit peu la communication bien
sûr ça vous a rappelé un peu la
conférence de presse de pochettino on va
dire gardant un oeil oui oui un petit
peu c'est marrant parce que ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure c'est que je crois
naceri qualifié employer le terme gagner
avec style
c'est mot pour mot ce qu'avait dit paul
chez tino lorsqu'il était arrivé au psg
donc il ya toujours un peu la même envie
au psg bat c'est de gagner d'avoir des
résultats tout en jouant bien et qu'à
chaque fois c'est la communication c'est
le nouveau première arrive oui mais lui
c'est le bon lui c'est bon c'est lui qui
va arriver ça on n'en sait rien bien sûr
maintenant ce qui est intéressant c'est
de savoir pourquoi le psg a choisi
christophe galtier
on a aussi eu c'est une question bien
évidemment sur zidane devant lui qui dès
nacera rifi a annoncé officiellement que
kristo gatti était le premier choix et
qu'il n'avait jamais eu de contacts avec
les détails j'ai le coup ne sais pas qui
c'est pas qu'ils aient alors c'est un
peu comme un très grand coach il a dit
voilà il le respecte énormément on sait
jamais pour plus tard c'est être utile
est-ce qu'on peut le croire quand il dit
ça
c'est difficile quand même à croire
parce que de tous nos confrères de la
plupart des médias soit en france même
en espagne à l'étranger sont que l'hymne
sur le fait le ps vous voulez zinedine
zidane convoité zinedine zidane il ya il
évidemment aucun nasa comme le psg a
toujours un petit peu convoitée pep
guardiola en sachant que les tags il ya
manchester city et qu' il faudrait
presque un miracle en fait pour que
équipes moins de certitudes pour p&g ça
peut pas se faire voilà si zidane là ça
ne pouvait pas se faire ce n'était pas
possible maintenant pg activer d'autres
pistes que christophe galtier il y en
avait d'autres ont parlé de ruben amorim
avant avant la conférence de presse il
eu d'autres nous qui ont circulé à
droite à gauche c'est normal d'avoir
d'avoir plusieurs pistes on n'a pas
toujours la première qu'on veut même si
le psg n'est pas forcément habitué à ça
en tout cas avec les joueurs on le vit
sa dernière saison avec des marcato
assez incroyable et chez qui gagnent
toujours un peu ses bras de fer une mare
mais si le pape est
maintenant c'est difficile de croire que
le psg ne voulait pas inné des zidane
effectivement ça peut servir plus tard
peut-être si l'opportunité se présente
mais aujourd'hui pga tu le paies j'ai
fait avec christophe galtier et sa part
est un vrai choix encore une fois quand
on pense à sa relation avec le campus on
à julien qui lui dit qu'effectivement a
priori kalt yves devrait être leur seul
leur second choix et c'était plutôt
zidane le premier
cas y karagounis la première fois que
j'entends un coach poser des règles dès
le début alors il a beaucoup été
interrogé sur la parce que c'est paris
et paris mais ça fonctionne comme ça
dans le vestiaire effectivement il a
voulu se montrer très autoritaire on
peut le dire oui il a surtout réaffirmé
ce que ce qu'il voulait je pense il l'a
dit un petit peu plus ou moins en
conférence de presse c'est que s'il fait
ça il sait aussi qu'il a le soutien de
sa direction le soutien de son président
s'est il sait ce qu'il peut dire est ce
qui ne peut pas dire est aujourd'hui peu
plus tôt dire ce qu'il a vraiment envie
de dire en tout cas ce qu'il veut voir
au psg parce qu'il a soutien de risques
en pause parce qu'ils vont dans le même
sens et parce que nasser al-khelaifi
délègue à ce niveau-là et laissé
entendre par exemple qu'un départ de
données que mam n'est pas inenvisageable
en tout cas de tous les égos combat ça
paraît aujourd'hui éventuellement
crédible ce qui paraît fou parce que
neymar était vraiment au centre du
projet avant et est la grande star du
psg
ejeie qui veut se séparer de neymar ça
se calme un signal fort dans le côté ça
suffit le bling bling maintenant on est
un club avant tout sérieux qui va qui va
droit donc là sucre christophe galtier a
pu réaffirmer sa position a pu affirmer
son caractère
a priori
en fait je me demandais tout à l'heure
depuis quand on a vu un entraîneur qui
arrive est autant dans les bonnes
conditions dans les bonnes dispositions
je pense que ça fait un moment que le
psg n'a pas eu un entraîneur qui arrive
autant dans le contexte dans un contexte
favorable avec une direction qui sait où
aller et qui est d'accord avec lui
finalement ce crash contre le real
madrid s'était pas une si mauvaise chose
peut-être ouais c'est peut-être c'est
peut-être le point de départ finalement
d'une meilleure aventure pour pour le
psg après évidemment il ya encore
beaucoup de questions sur la christophe
galtier il était un petit peu interrogé
là-dessus se trouve nyx pa une
inexpérience en ligue des champions
notamment sur la gestion du vestiaire
tous à le siffler c'est pas si ce sont
tant de grandes questions qui vont
publier le psg il ya les réussites égard
il ya aussi des doutes évidemment on
habille bowler justement qu'il me l'a
dit pendant l'année christophe galtier
face à des grosses têtes comme club pour
ancelotti en ligue des champions ça va
être dur est ce que l'expérience est là
c'est un peu ça la grande question
finalement oui c'est la grande question
et sur l'expérience on le disait avant
la conférence de presse combien
d'entraîneurs sont arrivés sans
expérience et ont tout de suite comme ça
gagner la ligue des champions
évidemment la jurisprudence zidane mais
qui encore une fois est assez spécial
parce qu'il était au club depuis des
années le vestiaire le voulait vraiment
il y avait tout un héritage au real
madrid il ya peut-être aussi pour le
coup quand même un petit héritage au psg
christophe galtier qui s'est notamment
attardé sur la question tactique donc
comment jouer avec ce psg là et qui a
laissé clairement comprendre que y aura
une défense à trois au pg s'est
clairement sur ce quoi il parle même si
lui est un grand adepte du 4-4-2 très
classique tout ça il a l'air d'avoir
déjà bien réfléchi il a laissé entendre
que ça va partir sur une défense à trois
au moins il sait il sait où il va le psg
a déjà joué qu une défense à trois la
saison dernière ça pas si mal marché que
ça ils ont les bons joueurs pour quand
même ils ont les joueurs qui
correspondent à sao tout cas ils ont des
joueurs de couloir intéressant notamment
nuno mendes achraf à kylie qui peuvent
être intéressants dans ce système là
qu'ils connaissent assez bien c'est un
système qui peut peut-être permettre
aussi d'avoir messi neymar de blessure
terrain de manière assez cohérente
encore à voir évidemment avec comment
est-ce que ça s'anime quand reste que
sept équipes ont joué en équipe ne pas
jouer a fait + 3 et jouer vraiment à 10
plus le gardien
ça sera pas mal de questions visiblement
christophe galtier déjà bien bien
réfléchir un petit peu répandue est ce
qu'on peut croire google tv il nous
parle de beau jeu ça que sert
d'entraîneur beau jeu christophe galtier
non c'est pas vraiment un entraîneur
beau jeu et lui même l'avait l'avait
laissé la table plus ou moins reconnu
lorsqu'il avait été champion de france
avec lille on l'a dit à l'heure où il
avait dit que certes sont ils n'avaient
pas été très beau mais qu'il avait joué
avec beaucoup de générosité de coeur
c'est comme comme le disait une autre
notre collègue christophe remise par un
de ses articles pour pour le figaro il
disait que malte et j'aimerais bien
entendre cette déclaration le psg n'a
pas été très beau mais a joué avec du
coeur et de la générosité
après une finale de ligue des champions
ça serait plutôt le péché s'en
contenterait largement je pense donc
donc il est avant tout pour ça
maintenant comme il l'a dit lui-même il
sait qu'il doit il se doit bien jouer il
sait aussi qu'il a un effectif qui n'a
rien à voir avec ce qu'il a connu
jusqu'à présent l'effectif n'a rien à
voir avec celui de l'île de nice avec
des joueurs il l'a dit lui-même il
utilisait le terme incroyable il a des
joueurs de très grand niveau et un petit
peu obligé d'offrir de la qualité de jeu
aujourd'hui aux supporters du pech david
astra qui je pense qu'entre un
entraîneur français va faire du bien
c'est le 3e entraîneur français depuis
les recrues et si kombouaré au début qui
n'a pas duré très longtemps laurent
blanc est maintenant christophe galtier
c'est assez rare aussi pour un
entraîneur comme ça de monter en france
est d'arriver à pas ce graal du psg
finalement oui c'est assez rare elle
c'est c'est surtout qu'en plus on a un
entraîneur français sera pu être
zinedine zidane mais ce sont ce sont
deux entraîneurs français n'est pas du
tout le même cv le même palmarès
évidemment dont christophe galtier il ya
un côté partie de saint-etienne qui
étaient à la limite je maintiens qu'il a
dû stabiliser pour monter avec lille
puis nice puis le psg d'escaladé un
petit peu maintenant est ce que c'est
bien pour le pg d'avoir un entraîneur
français je ne sais pas si ça va changer
grand grand chose je pense que ça peut
changer quelque chose ça part un peu
dans la communication notamment dans le
rapport avec les médias j'ai tendance à
penser que les médias seront peut-être
un peu plus bienveillant que avec un
entraîneur étranger en souvient surtout
de nay emery pour qui ça a été difficile
avec avec la presse
alors que galtier est quand même assez
assez apprécié a vraiment la cote en
france donc oui ça facilite un petit peu
ce niveau là ça peut être enlevé un
petit peu de pression maintenant ça va
pas tout pardonner ça n'empêche que
galtier va arriver avec beaucoup de
pression qu'il faudra rapidement du beau
jeu des résultats ça christophe galtier
qu'ils soient français ou étrangers il
n'y échappera par contre en cas de
réussite dans un club comme le psg pour
christophe galtier ça peut le faire
décoller sa carrière de façon au stratos
fric oui totalement parce que c'est un
entraîneur qui qui j'ai envie de dire
pour qui ça changerait vraiment vraiment
quelque chose on parlait digne et zidane
imaginons qu'un vilain je serai
entraîneur du psg sera un petit peu
c'est pas pour ça qu'il va retomber dans
l'anonymat ça restera un entraîneur qui
pourrait entraîner n'importe quel club
n'importe quel meilleur club au monde on
l'a vu tout seul qui pouvait
parfaitement rebondir parce qu'ils
avaient des acquis et aussi parce qu'il
a montré quand même de très bonnes
choses otg même si ça s'est mal finie la
longue à chelsea pour gagner la ligue
des champions christophe galtier il
n'arrive pas avec le même cv il est déjà
maintenant dans un autre niveau même si
ça ne se passe pas très bien au psg il
pourra dire j'ai été choisi par le psg
il va sûrement quand même montré des
choses j'ai du mal à croire que
christophe galtier va complètement se
planter sera il sera viré dans six mois
je pense qu'il a les capacités pour
montrer des choses il varie avec une
équipe assez motivés avec une direction
qui va dans le bon sens qui va en tout
cas dans le même sens que lui sur un
mercato où ils travaillent ensemble ils
travaillent main dans la main lassus
christophe gathiary vraiment avec les
bonnes les bonnes dispositions et il ya
le rendre à parler par wordpress neymar
et meetic sont arrivés en avance pour
cette reprise et de l'arrivée de lundi
prochain ils sont déjà là est-ce que
c'est bruce ci est ce que c'est de la
com qu'est-ce qu'on pense de tout ça
c'est un peu difficile de savoir est-ce
que c'est lié à l'arrivée de christophe
galtier est ce que c'est peut-être juste
iea à la pression qui fait mine et sert
elle qualifie dans différentes
interviews où il avait parlé cette fin
du bling bling détaillait tout ça
de mettre la pression à peu aux joueurs
et de montrer aussi des changements avec
le changement la direction sportive on
peut soupçonner que oui il ya eu un
effet au psg de se motiver un petit peu
et de se rendre compte que la situation
est un peu une urgente et sérieuse
j'ai pas dire critique mais le psg doit
aujourd'hui se remettre à l'endroit les
derniers mois avec punch qui n'ont été
très très pénibles on est très très long
la fin de saison a été catastrophique
calamiteux j'ai demandé aux joueurs de
jouer il n'y avait plus rien à jouer on
se rappelle avec la relation que les
supporters qu'ils venaient qu'il
sifflait leurs joueurs pendant presque
90 minutes au parc des princes ça a été
vraiment vraiment laborieux à ce niveau
là on a presque l'impression que le psg
doit un peu se racheter on va pas dire
que le pg était en vacances avant d'être
en vacances mais peut-être un petit peu
quand même parce que la fin de saison
elle a été longue et sans enjeu
donc oui le psg doit arriver motivé
c'est plutôt quand même un bon signal de
voir les sud américains mais marc
messier compagnie revenir une semaine en
avance c'est quoi l'objectif aujourd'hui
pour christophe galtier s'il gagne pas
la ligue des champions au fait on n'a
pas une question sur objectifs pour la
série fille qui a répondu pendant cinq
minutes à côté c'était magnifique
c'était une très belle langue de bois
s'invite à côté il n'a pas donné les
objectifs précis en titre de ligue 1
c'est façon évidente c'est évident une
petite coupe pour ajouter en plus
normalement ça devrait le faire sauf si
problème on ne sait jamais et ligue des
champions
il faut christophe galtier est loin
parce que sinon la vraie question c'est
est ce que le psg arrive en disant qu'il
veut gagner la ligue des champions cette
saison et si ce n'est pas qu'à est ce
que ce sera un échec je pense qu'il faut
prendre on est obligé de prendre en
compte le fait que christophe galtier
dans sa première saison au psg dans sa
première saison dans un tel club il va
quasiment découvrir la ligue des
champions la fine font campagne une
phase de groupes avec lille il n'y avait
pas grand chose à en retenir
il arrive voilà christophe galtier
n'arrivent pas vraiment pour avec un
statut de je vais vous faire gagner
ligue des champions je suis l'homme qui
va le faire comme pourrait être ainsi
dan s'il était arrivé est ce que ce sera
un échec si le psg gagne la ligue des
champions non pas forcément pas
forcément parce qu'il faudra prendre en
compte évidemment le contexte le pg
services comme une équipe qui s'est
arrêté en huitièmes de finale c'est une
énorme désillusion un club qui avait
quand même fait une finale en 2020 et
une demi-finale si je ne m'abuse en 2021
face à manchester city
donc le psg repart un type en arrière
imaginons que le psg fait un beau
parcours jusqu'en demi finales en étant
très sérieux en luttant vraiment
jusqu'au bout le psg peut sortir d'une
campagne de ligue des champions
s'arrêter en quart en demi-finale et
dire ok c'est encourageant pour la suite
le psg peut faire une compagnie des
champions encourageantes sans que ce
soit un drame une catastrophe donc non
le psg ne sera pas en échec forcément
s'il échoue en ligue des champions
maintenant il faudra voir encore une
fois le contexte de comment ils échouent
le psg ne peut plus se permettre de
vivre des choses comme il a vécu cette
saison la saison passée avec le real
madrid qui sauvent match et il arrive un
peu libéré je pense de ce point-là
libérer d'une certaine pression
médiatique encore une fois parce qu'il a
la cote en france parce qu'il arrive
avec un bon statut une belle image
maintenant le psg dans son ensemble
reste quand même sous pression pour la
ligue des champions parce que il peut
pas non plus attendre encore dix ans
avant avant de la gagner alors vous
n'hésitez pas à me dire ce que vous en
pensez vous vous pensez que là que le
psg arrivera ou en ligue des champions
cette année est ce que vous pensez que
aussi qu'ils vont remporter le titre
automatiquement comme ils le font sauf
quand ils ont christophe galtier faso où
luis compost qui construisent équipe
comme monaco et lille même maintenant il
faut racheter tous les gens qui leur met
des bâtons dans les roues finalement on
peut dire ça d'ailleurs on peut
peut-être se pencher un peu sur le sur
le mercato parce qu'il en a été un peu
question il y ait une phrase un peu
forte aussi c'est cette histoire
christophe galtier un effectif resserré
et on sait que pour le psg c'est un
problème un peu de faire partir des
joueurs il y encore il y aura encore une
grande partie du bateau qui sera dédiée
à ça oui c'est un peu tous les 6 mois
quasiment on se retrouve sur ce plateau
pour dire alors les amis les uns désir
du pg ils partent ils partent pas en
patois donc peut-être ils vont enfin
partir en tout cas on espère du côté du
psg qu'on va enfin des coques décanter
la situation de certains joueurs on
pense notamment à amaro aicardi à julian
draxler voir en ce moment à leandro
paredes
donc est-ce que p g va enfin de se
séparer de ses joueurs il le faut il le
faut à un moment donné parce que
christophe galtier je pense qu'il a
raison lorsqu'il dit que des joueurs qui
ne jouent pas sont malheureux surtout
qu'il ya je pense ne pas jouer et ne pas
jouer il ya ne pas jouer et jouer quand
même 600 700 minutes dans la saison 15
20 matchs et être ok avec le fait juste
de rendre des services en et en ayant un
statut de remplaçant c'est le cas par
exemple je prends l'exemple d'un joueur
au real madrid le macho qui se
contentent parfaitement de ce rôle là et
s'il faut dépanner dans un quart de
finale de ligue des champions parce
qu'il ya des blessés des suspendus il
est ravi de le faire et qui joue pas il
est content d'en groupe dans le club
maintenant le psg peut avoir aussi des
joueurs comme ça mais peut pas avoir des
joueurs qui sont quasiment hors du
groupe comme un layvin kurzawa par
exemple owen nous en parle le bureau
chômeurs de france voilà c'est c'est un
joueur c'est pas possible d'avoir un
jour dans une telle situation dans le
club surtout quand il y en a trois ou
quatre comme sa saleté léger doit
absolument s'activer parce que
effectivement un jour triste ce n'est
pas bon pour le club ce n'est pas bon
pour l'ambiance du groupe là dessus il
faut il faut travailler je pense que
l'objectif principal du psg il est de se
débarrasser de ses joueurs qu'ils ne
serviront à rien c'est une réalité
qu'ils savent qu'ils ne seront là pour
rien et qui ne pourront rien espérer de
super légers il faut de se débarrasser
de ces joueurs là d'abord avant vraiment
de l'espérer recruter et de construire
effectifs et christophe galtier on a
parlé d'ailleurs il a dit que plus il y
avait des gens malheureux dans le
vestiaire - la performance allait être
au rendez vous on alexis gaudrée kindy
paris va gagner à lille à la gare
facilement lemay ligue des champions je
ne sens pas du tout galtier doit
construire long terme le problème c'est
qu'il voie le temps de course très
longue terme et le psg ils sont pas
vraiment spécialiste de construire sur
le long terme en ses proches du foot
d'aujourd'hui c'est que le long terme en
fait c'est la semaine prochaine c'est le
long terme c'est mixte ça n'existe plus
vraiment dans le football qu'est ce
qu'on dit qu'est ce que le long terme en
fait est-ce que c'est l'année prochaine
est ce que c'est dans trois ans dans
cinq ans dans le pdg construit pas un
projet sur cinq ans pour arriver à 5 ans
dans cinq ans de maturité ça marche pas
comme ça aujourd'hui pour le psg
le psg veut veut construire mais doit
forcément être un petit peu dans
l'urgence c'était le cas avec avec avec
cette rumeur zinedine zidane de l'idée
de vie de gagner la ligue des champions
qui va tout de suite apporté des
miracles avec christophe galtier on a
forcément un petit peu cette exigence là
on peut pas ne pas du tout la voir alors
certes y'a l'inexpérience tout ça mais
christophe galtier toile vite montré des
choses il pourra pas dire bon cette
année juste j'essaye il pourra pas dire
c'est pas grave si on n'est pas champion
de france par exemple ça a c'est
inenvisageable pour le pg c'est arrivé à
aulnoye aymeries en 2010 est celle là
coûter très très cher
donc le psg ne peut pas avoir cette
expérience mais en même temps il faut
être obligé on est obligé d'être un
petit peu patient et que ce psg avec
christophe galtier avait fui ce camp
pause parce qu'ils viennent d'arriver
parce qu'ils peuvent pas forcément non
plus réalisé des miracles du jour au
lendemain opel qui le dit paris doit se
réveiller et vite julien mais qui est
malheureux psg et yves tourre surpayés
sans même qu'on leur demande des
résultats elle est pas belle la vie
c'est vrai qu'il ya aussi sacs qui
rentrent en jeu il ya des joueurs qui
sont très contents on parle par exemple
du lan trachsler qui ne joue plus depuis
qu à trois 3 ans à priori à peu près il
n'a pas forcément envie de partir
finalement oui ils veulent ils peuvent
accepter de partir mais aussi ne pas non
plus en fait revoir autant leurs
conditions à la baisse parce que c'est
aussi problème du pg et ses problèmes de
dos de gros clubs pas non plus
spécifique au pg n'exagérons pas mais on
se retrouve avec un très gros salaire et
en fait on joue plus et on se dit bon
ben ok je veux bien partir mais c'est
dans ce cas je veux pas couper mon
salaire par cinq
donc oui c'est compliqué forcément pour
ses joueurs de les revendre de les faire
partir parce que le psg ne peut pas non
plus gaspiller de l'argent comme ça
parce qu'il ya aussi des règles un peu
du fair play financier qu'il faut
équilibrer les comptes donc le psg se
retrouve souvent un petit peu coincé et
ses joueurs ils veulent bien partir mais
ils veulent bien retrouver du temps de
jeu ils veulent bien peut-être gagner un
petit peu moins d'argent mais ils
veulent pas non plus tellement de se
sacrifier en donner il se tourne vers le
psg leur dise que c'est eux aussi qu'ils
randonnaient salaire là et que
maintenant c'est à eux de s'adapter à
ces conditions est-ce qu'ils ont ce qui
leur ont fait signe au départ aboubacar
sow qui me dit il ya trop de pression
sur les coach du psg est un grand club
donc quand il ya un bon club il faut
forcément de essayer de faire venir
enfin de d'avoir des résultats et quand
ça marche pas effectivement ils sont pas
forcément très très patient on va dire
non ils sont pas très patient après
quand on regarde généralement j'ai pas
souvenir d'un entraîneur du psg qui a
été viré de la première crise ils ont
souvent une deuxième voire une troisième
chance ou la galerie l'art montana et la
perte du titre contre monaco il a refait
une saison plus dans les conditions très
compliquées mais il a refait une saison
plus tôt de chez tino n'a pas été viré
au premier échec ou à la première
tension
et même sur l'élimination face au real
madrid
aurait toujours pu imaginer que le psg
aurait pu le garder mais la fin de
saison est tellement catastrophique et
qu' l'attention tellement palpable en
fait entre potes chez tino de la
direction l'a senti puccino nous
voulaient toutes façons plus continuer
ici qu'il en avait un peu ça claque et
donc le psg n'a pas pu le garder f1
s'est désigné finalement à le payer
peut-être un chèque un peu importants un
peu à contrecoeur mais le pays un chèque
pour au moins faire un peu de ménage
donc le psg oui il va avoir un peu cette
impatience on s'aimerait christophe
galtier mais encore une fois il arrive
avec du crédit il arrive avec une
bienveillance des médias il arrive avec
un directeur sportif qui l'a demandé qui
veut travailler avec lui qui va
construire avec lui
j'ai pas trop de doutes sur le fait que
ça peut marcher avec le vestiaire sauf
quand il a comme la réputation
globalement de bien s'entendre avec ses
joueurs d'avant une relation assez forte
assez humaine ne pas être autoritaire
même pas être extrêmement duo à chercher
le conflit alors encore une fois ça
s'est mal fini avec nice parce qu'il ya
des conflits que sa direction qui ont
déteint sur le vestiaire pas parce qu'il
ya eu des conflits avec ses joueurs
c'est je pense une nuance très très
importante donc là dessus galtier a
quand même le temps je pense d'arrivée
de poser ses marques et de travailler
assez sereinement alors julien qui nous
parle de kombouaré qui s'était fait des
sorties rapidement parce qu'il ne
faisait pas assez bling bling oui mais
parce que c'était aussi une autre époque
que si venait de reprendre le psg et il
y avait 1 40 fchi loti qui traînait par
là et quand on est le psg et qu'on veut
faire un peu brillé les stars bah c'est
mieux d'avoir
1 d'abord à caryotype d'antoine
kombouaré sur le bien sûr l'opportunité
carlo ancelotti il était très difficile
à refuser pour un psg qui d'un psg
version qsi qui venait à peine de naître
qui venait de sortir de terre qui devait
ensuite enclenché sur le mercato qu'il y
avait un recrutement ambitieux et qui a
marché ensuite avec zlatan ibrahimovic
agossi nouvelle compagnie
c'est un contexte totalement différent
je pense donc effectivement gatier wyss
a le plus bingbing c'est pas une idée
zidane zidane ça fait un peu rêver mais
c'est apparemment le psg ne s'est pas
qu'ils hésitent à dix ils ont jamais
entendu parler lui il faut faire plus de
contacts mais voilà ça c'est un petit
peu rêver maintenant christophe galtier
ça reste un entraîneur qui a vraiment du
crédit au sein de cette direction
aujourd'hui on l'a bien vu et on l'a
bien compris avec les plus campos alors
on préfère un petit point mercato du
coup on a parlé de l'effectif il doit
être réduit est ce qu'il ya des arrivées
qui pourrait arriver on a parlé beaucoup
de 2000 entry nar récemment est ce que
c'est une piste assez envisagée par le
psg ça semble être une piste très
sérieuse des derniers échos il y avait
un accord en tout cas déjà entre le psg
et screen hier sur les termes d'un
contrat sur un contrat de 3 5 ans avec
lequel salaire tout ça semblait assez
assez ficelé maintenant faut que le
péché négocier avec l'inter milan qui a
fixé un prix le psg trouve que c'est un
peu cher le psg c'est de mettre juin
baxter apparemment dans la balance une
terre n'est pas très emballé par l'idée
donc il faut un petit peu négociées
wisques rien ça semble quand même assez
chaud maintenant quand faut-il trouver
un accord avec l'inter milan pour
pouvoir avoir un défenseur de plus alors
que par exemple reste mais qui permet
d'annoncer un petit peu lui sur sur le
départ et on parle aussi de neymar
peut-être qu'il pourrait partir ça c'est
une possibilité alors christophe galtier
il a été évidemment interrogé là-dessus
on a vu tout à l'heure en conférence de
presse lui il est clairement qu'il veut
neymar qui veut garder neymar est ce
qu'on croit quand je vois je voyais avec
elle qualifie ou christophe galtier dire
on est ouvert au départ de neymar
publiquement ça ferait un petit peu
bizarre ça ferait tout un feuilleton
je pense que le départ de neymar est
quand même assez peu envisageable parce
qu'il ya vraiment la question économique
qui se pose quel club peut acheter
neymar aujourd'hui quel club peut
acheter mes mains c'est un salaire
colossal quel club payer le salaire de
neymar on parlait tout à l'heure des
indésirables comme aux indésirables qui
ne veulent pas trop quitter le psg parce
que par après tout ils se plaisent à
paris ils sont bien ils ont leurs
salaires némin n'échappe pas à cette
règle les imams n'y échappe pas parce
qu'il a un salaire énorme il est plutôt
bien dans la vie parisienne il semble
bien dans le vestiaire finalement
pourquoi est-ce qu'il forcerait son
départ du psg lui n'a pas forcément de
raison il sait que s'il est là en
principe il va jouer si jamais il met un
petit peu les efforts les ingrédients
mais je ne pense pas que neymar soit
totalement déconnecté du psg les plus
envie d'être là bas mais encore une fois
il est revenu une semaine en avance
comme les autres de ses vacances ça
montre un petit peu de l'application je
pense pas qu'un et mac un départ de
neymar soit vraiment à l'étude du côté
du pays est ce que au niveau des
arrivées est ce qu'on en sait un peu
plus ce qu'on sait qu'il pourrait venir
au psg oui alors il ya toujours des
rumeurs notamment de gianluca scama
qu'attaquant attaquant italien de
sassuolo qui est très prometteur qui
cotisent et pas les plus gros clubs
italiens depuis quelques années
notamment de la juventus on en parle
beaucoup on dit qu'on n'est pas loin
d'un accord pour un transfert autant de
têtes de 50 millions d'euros c'est quand
même très grosses sommes pour un
attaquant qui a une expérience assez
assez limité maintenant à voir aussi on
peut se poser la question dans ce cas
d'un attaquant 50 millions d'euros quand
on a même un messie mbappé comment est
ce qu'on fait jouer en fait tous ces
joueurs là il ya aussi encore des
rumeurs sur renato sanchez son milieu de
terrain tous un chef qui s'entendait
très bien avec christophe gars qui avec
lille galtier qui a vraiment réussi à
bien exploiter son potentiel ces marées
noires assez crédible n'a encore faut-il
qu'elles se concrétisent ya l'assimilant
aussi qu'il ya ces choses sur renato
sanchez bon là aujourd'hui c'est un peu
les principales rumeurs il y aura aussi
la question du gardien la khl quel qui a
plus ou moins répondu et a laissé
entendre que lui veut vraiment numéro un
que l'alternance de la roma navas
c'était un peu compliqué sur les
derniers échos qu'ils y avait les deux
gardiens n'avait plus l'air très très
chaude veut se partager le poste comme
ça parce que ça leur convenait pas trop
ça aussi on peut s'attendre à ce que le
psg deux tranches pour de bon sur ce
dossier est ce qu on pourrait avoir une
grande star on parle de une rumeur
ronaldo qui voit arriver parce que
ronaldo veut quitter manchester à ce qui
peut arriver est-ce qu'il peut aller à
paris sachant qu'on a déjà trois joueurs
devant qui courent pas c'est ce qu'on
aura le pas 4e ça paraît quand même très
compliqué aujourd'hui surtout si cinéma
reste au psg je pense que c'est quand
même la tendance connemara reste au psg
je suis pas sûr que ronaldo je pense je
pense que on aurait tendance qu'elle n'a
pas à se moquer temps scott de nasser
al-khelaifi qui parle de ne plus être en
mode plus est avec les paillettes faire
signer cristiano ronaldo ça ressemble
pas vraiment à ce discours qu'a tenu le
psg non ça je pense que la rumeur
ronaldo pg on peut déjà les cartes et et
on parle aussi de robert clément de ce
liquide devrait quitter le bayern munich
est ce que le psg aurait la manne
financière pour l'attirer dans l'absolu
on peut toujours imaginer que le psg
trouve les moyens de de se débrouiller
financièrement parce qu'il l'a toujours
fait jusqu'à présent et le pg jamais eu
de problème en tout cas financier n'a
jamais pas recruter un joueur parce que
il n'y avait pas les moyens maintenant
le problème du psg pour pertes et rondot
ce qui s'appelle fc barcelone le barça
qui semble vouloir les au dos qu'il est
au dossier qui semble vouloir le barça
il ya que le bayern en fait qui fait
obstacle entre les deux
les négociations ça me plaît quand même
plutôt bien avancées entre le marcel
bayart après il faut toujours régler des
petits détails il faut qu'on peut faire
de la place économiquement du côté du
barça est ce que le psg peut s'incruster
dans ce deal là c'est quand même très
peu probable encore une fois le pg
offensivement je pense qu'il a son
effectif c'est pas pour rajouter les
stars c'est peut-être plus pour ajouter
un joueur comme scama cas on a dit tout
à l'heure attaquants italiens plus
prometteurs plus pour l'avenir à ces
jeunes qui l'a 21 22 ans donc on est
plus sur un joueur comme ça qui pourrait
arriver en attaque que les ventes de ce
qui effectivement et on a d'ailleurs
dans les commentaires beaucoup de gens
qui disent que le vent de ce qui signera
sûrement au barça plutôt plutôt vers
barcelone que paris selon leurs
informations
écoutez merci beaucoup en tout cas
sébastien d'avoir est avec moi
aujourd'hui pour parler de tout ça merci
à vous d'avoir être très nombreux à nous
suivre pour cette présentation de
christophe galtier voilà le nouvel
entraîneur ce n'est pas zidane pour le
psg c'est christophe galtier et on verra
ce que ça donne à la fin de la saison je
crois que c'est julien qui a dit ça il
faut arrêter de blablater et laisser la
place aux quarts c'est ce qui va se
passer maintenant enfin maintenant on a
quand même encore encore quelques
semaines avant qu'elles ont un petit
mois vous plains ayant pris un petit
bout avant que la ligue 1 reprennent et
voilà et donc moi je vous dis à bientôt
pour de nouveaux lives sur figaro l'est